all right hello everyone please welcome
Sol with his talk same API a different
execution Paul is sorry Saul is from
Kuan site so give her on to applause and
I guess we'll start thanks everyone for
being here I'm really excited to be here
with all of you and shares some work
that we've been doing at Kuan site for
the past year or so so I'm gonna start
this is just a little preview so I'm not
gonna go over right now but it was just
to kind of whet your appetite and I'm
gonna start with just some Python code
we're gonna go into some history that
might be relevant and then we're gonna
come back to this example and back to
meta dsl which is this framework that
i'm gonna be talking about today and
just to situate the talk the kind of the
goal is thinking about the future of
data science and machine learning and
python and making sure that python is
still performant and accessible to new
users moving forward in the ecosystem so
it's a pretty broad kind of category but
that this is kind of an approach that
when you're taking and I'll show you why
maybe it's useful so if we look at this
function and you all read this in Python
this is big enough yeah so what we're
doing here is we're creating an array of
a bunch of numbers we're adding them to
themselves and then we're indexing
so this code is probably pretty looks
pretty normal to all of you if you know
Python but I want to highlight some sort
of something about it here is that we're
making a separation between allocating
our memory doing our computation and
then you know saving that to a result
and then doing some more computation so
it's a very sequential kind of process
right python is like you're doing some
work you save it to a variable you do
some more work and you save that to a
new variable and if we look at sort of
like time right we think about we're
allocating you know this range of
numbers we're adding them and then we're
indexing
so if we want to say let's make this
code faster right what can we do well we
can make each of these steps take less
time right by running less instructions
on our computer and so this is what
numpy lets us do right it's this is a
lot faster and but it looks very similar
we're allocating a bunch of memory and
filling it up we're doing some operation
and then we're indexing again so we have
a similar kind of structure where you
have time going down and your computer
is doing things sequentially but we're
just compressing each of these
operations so that they run quicker
right and so this is how we can optimize
like our scientific code with like our
existing numpy kind of sci-fi stack
thanks look at that fancy suite so this
kind of architecture is called the von
Neumann architecture and so we see this
kind of like pipeline here we have our
CPU we have our memory right and so
we're going back and forth between our
CPU and our memory
we're fetching an instruction we're
generating the you know the the data
that it's operating on and then we're
performing that operation and we're
storing the results so this fits you
know if you know Python this fits kind
of like in our mental model how Python
works and how many programming languages
today work so this is just stealing from
Wikipedia you say a von Neumann language
is a language that kind of copies this
architecture but at a higher level all
right so this is kind of how we're used
to computing and so this is so this is
great we can we can increase our
performance by running our instructions
faster right by getting new Hardware CPU
that runs faster or we can run less
instructions right and so this is the
the numpy approach right where we're
doing the same work but we're actually
running less instructions on our CPU so
it grows
quicker and so we're gonna look at a
couple issues with each of these points
here and why that might need changes in
the Python ecosystem to accommodate like
going forward so the first one is a
hardware slowdown or hardware is not
getting as quicker anymore as like it
was so you see here this is a the
frequency of your CPU so like you know
three gigahertz two gigahertz that kind
of thing we can see it's pretty much
flatlined right in the past like 10-15
years we can also see like single thread
performance so this is if you're just
running a Python program it's also like
flatlining and so you see though that
there's actually transistors so the
number of like you know little hardware
units to do computation is still going
up exponentially so what's going on why
aren't our chips getting faster well
we're getting more cores right to do our
work so this is why you see things like
multi-core and then other kinds of pull
this up yeah so this is a you know
there's some there's some kind of like
physics behind this and some computing
laws about it like you might have heard
of Moore's law or Dennard scaling and
that kind of you know captures these
relationships but as as those are ending
yet we're seeing a switch to multi-core
processors and so we see a bunch of
other things as well we're moving to
GPUs multi processing we have more
caching we have pipelining in the CPU
where it will try to execute a bunch of
instructions at the same time and hope
that one of them is the one you wanted
right so these kind of like things that
really break with our mental model of
how Python works and how of Unknowing
man-machine works because it's no longer
just run this save it to memory run this
save it to memory right we're having
parallelism we're having different types
of hardware that aren't represented by
this architecture and so we call this
von Neumann machine right we have the
processor in the array we can call this
kind of like the slowdown that happens
when we try to keep doing more
operations the von Neumann bottleneck
and back in 1977 John Backus was as he
was accepting his Turing award he was
complaining about this bottleneck not
just because it was slow you know
physically but because it was an
intellectual bottleneck because it
encourages you to think about one
operation at a time right instead of
thinking about your whole program as a
unit you're thinking about hey I have
this one a range you know can I speed it
up in numpy I have this one ad how do i
speed this up right so encourages you to
think in these little blocks and it
doesn't let you make the kinds of
optimizations that you need to really
get increased performance and optimize
this Hardware right so this has also had
consequences right the software is
responding to this so this is some gift
from the tensorflow website and you know
some kind of idea of how their their
tensor flow graph works so if you
haven't used tensor flow it's a deep
learning library and it lets you write
you know machine learning models and the
difference between it in something like
numpy is that it represents things as a
graph right you represent a graph of
your computations in some way and then
you execute them as one so it lets you
talk about this hot like this larger
conceptual unit than just a single
operation or like a block of operations
right so it has they found it very
useful in being able to then compile to
different architectures so the reason
why tensorflow uses this is so that they
can then distribute your computation or
compile it to GPUs or compile it to
other hardware that's not based on you
know the von Neumann kind of
architecture like Python is so this is
this is harder like it's more
complicated right this is like a more
complicated world that we're moving into
then you know the sort of where we have
been and ten years ago or something
because we didn't have to worry about
parallelism and all these other kinds of
you know different hardware's so this is
a little visualization I tried to put
together looking at if you're starting
in Google and in Python what are the
different types of hardware you can hit
and what are the different basically the
different graphs or different frameworks
that you need to target to get high
performance so you notice here that
Intel has its own framework called n
graph which is like a tensor flow graph
but it's specific for Intel chips
basically so if you want to run on their
special new neural network processor you
have to get your code into n graph first
which is its own representation of how
you're gonna do your machine learning
model how you can do your computation
right and same for AMD arm and Nvidia so
the point is that as a developer you
don't want to have to care about this
right you don't want to have to think
about oh I need to rewrite all my code
so that I can use this new Nvidia chip
that they just released right you like
that's not how it is today you just use
numpy and they can compile a new version
of numpy for a specific you know CPU
processor and you can get increased
performance without having to change
your code and that's how it should be
for this kind of like graph based layout
as well you should just write your code
once and then be able to target all
these different intermediate
representations that are you know coming
alive in these different hardware so
then I want to connect this to the
community open source right because
there's there's a lot of things we love
about well the reason why we're here is
not just like the technical details of
how to do this but it's that we're doing
it as a community we're doing it in a
distributed manner it's not just one
company coming and saying well we built
this stack for you and it works great
and we can target all this Hardware just
you know buy into what we you know kind
of our way of doing things and you'll be
fine like that's not the world that I
want to live in at least so we want to
be able to support you know all these
kind of diverse libraries that I'll
build on each other
but still be able to target all these
different types of hardware in a
performant way today and into the future
all right so we want Python to still be
a language that people are using to
write high-performance computing machine
learning software but we don't want it
to be consolidated all within like one
stack right because because it's a hard
problem we haven't decided to solve it
as a community and so there are you know
asked right number these are solutions
to this but using them together like
today as a user is not always it snow is
obvious how this fits together as an
ecosystem right like how do I use I
can't image on a distributed manner with
GPUs right you know it's a lot of work
to do that today there needs to be sort
of like so what we need is kind of
software to bridge the gap where we can
represent all these different libraries
and they can play together so that's
what I've been exploring at least with
this meta DSL project for decentralized
you know cooperation on solving this
problem sweet so yeah we have tools you
know so I'm going to show a little
example of a fake array API we have a
get item we have an ad and we we can
make a raise with this a range function
one thing you might notice is that
there's no actual definitions here right
this isn't saying how these functions
are computed it's just specifying the
API for this mock array library with
using pythons typing right so you you
know we can and and then we can write a
function like this that takes two arrays
adds them and indexes and we can
actually call that on on a range and we
see we have this sort of you know what
would what will be computed we have a
representation of what we want to
compute we don't know how to compute it
yet we don't even know you know should
we run this on Python tree we run this
on tensorflow
I don't know yet at this point all we
have is the description of what we want
to compute in Python right and so this
is this can people see how this
translates here or there are there
questions there I've been looking at
this for a while so for me it's you know
makes sense but I think yeah please let
me know if you have any questions
haha this - um this is slightly darker
yeah that's a good question
yeah so let's see so then we might say
okay so we have this kind of abstract
representation of what we want to
compute now let's actually use numpy to
compute it right because we can use
numpy to do these operations so here is
where we start to get interesting now we
can start to say hey we have some we can
create an array from a numpy array and
then we define how all these rules work
on arrays of numpy arrays so we say hey
if you're taking an a range of something
turn that into calling numpy a range and
then turning that into array if you're
adding two arrays add the inside numpy
arrays and then turn that into this
array that we've defined right and same
for indexing so now if we execute this
we see we get a result and not only that
we can step through this execution and
we can see oh well before that it was
calling getitem right on this array and
and before that it was adding two arrays
and then we can see our initial write is
what we had before so we can see how we
start from this kind of abstract
representation and then we you know
through executing these replacement
rules that we've defined here we can get
to our result and so the key point is
that this the person who writes this
could be a different person than the
person who writes this so one project
could write an interface and another
project could write a back-end and we
can separate that work out but we can
still cooperate as an ecosystem together
right and the user can still use the
same function right there so using this
function here they're doing the same
thing here and I all I have to do is
import this library or you know set some
configure what have you and they can run
their code so as a user you don't have
to depend on the specific implementation
you just depend on this
generic sort of you know that the API
right that's you depend on the API and
then you can import libraries to define
different ways to execute it so one
another advantage though so so this is
like you know computing it eagerly with
numpy we can also see sort of how we
might compile this in some way right so
instead of creating an array from an
umpire array we're gonna create an array
from a string so here we're passing in
some symbolic array a may be to this
function and instead of so we say if
we're adding two symbolic arrays we're
just going to create a new string that
has the addition and if we're doing
indexing we're creating a new array that
has the indexing so then the result that
we get is this string of adding two
arrays and then indexing so this is kind
of a toy is definitely a toy example
here but instead of creating a string
right this could create LVM code or you
know then you could eval this string and
python so what you end up as a result
here is not actually a result it's a a
compilation of what you want to do right
so you're separating out hey this is
what I want to do and this is I've
compiled it in some way to some form and
you know this could be a tensor flow
graph right so then you could then send
this off the tensor flow and it could
execute it so that's kind of the vision
that we're moving towards and the other
advantage of having these things in a
symbolic form is that then we can write
optimizations right so here we we might
notice that we're adding two arrays and
then we're indexing
so that's a bit inefficient so instead
we can index first and then add right
because if you're adding first you're
doing all these additions and then
you're just picking out one element like
you didn't need all those Eila you need
to add all those other elements it's
kind of a waste of time so instead you
can index first and then add and then
you're just you know getting the result
that you need so this is kind of an
example of how looking at the program as
a whole right can give you more
optimizations because you can do less
work if you look at the larger chunk
right the larger conceptual unit then
just the little operations and so we've
defined this rule here and then if we
execute it we see we still start with
our original array here and then but our
first rule is this optimize right so
it's it's switched it so now we're doing
a get item we're doing adding a get item
instead instead of get item an add and
then as we compile it we can see we get
this array here right so we're we're
indexing first and then we're adding how
am i doing on on time not much okay
sweet okay great now I'll go into this
so the other thing you know so this kind
of optimization is still very specific
right like we wouldn't want to have to
write this kind of optimization for
every array operation because it's like
you could you know kind of invent any
number of these types of up you know
things to replace so instead what we can
think about instead of thinking about we
can think about our arrays as functions
themselves so here we're defining a new
array API that's abstract and we're
saying it has two methods right it has a
shape and it has this indexing method
and it has ADD so it has three methods
and we create it using a shape and a
function so instead of thing about array
is like a chunk of memory we can think
about it as just a mapping from your
indexes that you provide to the value
right so for like a range you pass in
you know you you index two into a range
and you're going to get two back right
so you can think about as a function
mapping your indices to the values so if
we represent our arrays like this then
we can kind of get these types of
optimizations for free because what we
end up compiling is a function that
represents our final array right and
it's got squishes down all the
operations into just one array so we can
see this for this example here
we can define yet the shape and the
indexing function and then we can define
how to convert from our original array
to this abstract array and then when we
so we still we start initially right the
same thing that we have but when we run
it through this kind of replacement we
get back some abstract array a and we're
indexing it by five and in this case now
it's a vector of integers and we have
five here and then we're adding it so
we've gotten this optimization out that
we wrote above manually for free here
because we're thinking about arrays more
generally and more mathematically than
we were before so the point is that if
you you can start from one kind of array
here and end up in another kind of array
so you might have your numpy API is this
initial one that's for users and then as
you're doing your replacements right you
end up in another API that's more
suitable for compilation and for
optimization so you can have these
different stages and these different
representations as you're moving along
the pipeline and different people can
maintain all of those and define
translations between them right so yeah
there's this great blog post pokeweed oh
and I love this photo in it so I wanted
to end with this photo and a quote from
computing for everybody the grant that
he wrote in the early 2000s where he
said we're looking forward to a future
where every computer use there will be
able to open the hood of their computer
and make improvements the applications
inside so I think this is really
applicable to our ecosystem like we want
every user to be able to open the hood
to their machine learning pipeline to
their data science pipeline and make
improvements inside right we I don't
like personally I don't want to live in
a world where there's one you know group
of people making the optimizations and
building the frameworks and another that
are users that have no control over you
know what they're doing or optimizing it
we should be able to share those
responsibilities and be able to
cooperate
on you know building these optimizations
together as a community because I think
that will lead to more innovation and
you know just more interesting work yeah
so I think I have some time for
questions yeah thank you all right
whoever has question just raise your
hand up I'll give you the microphone
very interesting work pretty pretty
advanced language engineering there if I
understood correctly there are two kinds
of rules there's one where you're
essentially writing overloaded operators
and then the second kind where you're
rewriting something that was already
written in a different syntax and you
can you clarify the interaction between
two sure um so there's just one real
type of rule so if we let's go back to
this example
so everything in meta DSL is an
expression and so you build up normally
in Python when you call functions right
something happens instead of meta DSL
all you do is you record I call this
function with these arguments right and
so this builds up a graph of what you
want to do and then you write rules that
say when I see this thing in the graph
replace it with this thing in the graph
and we have a helpful way let me go back
to this one I think it's nice so here
you can see this is a rule and this is
the when it sees this in the graph it
should replace it with this right so the
the nice thing about this is it's this
all checks with my PI and it's it just
looks like you're writing Python you
don't have to learn a new meta
programming kind of language you just
write when I see this I want it to be
replaced with this right so that's
that's the entirety that's like all meta
DSL gives you as those two blocks really
and then what you do with it like what
kinds of domains you build how they
translate between each other is the
problem that we have to solve together
right and that we have to
figure out I don't know if that little
clear anymore questions we have a lot of
time so so maybe to give you a sense of
where this is heading next I don't know
if any of you know ml IR is a framework
from Google that does something pretty
similar to this so it's a it's coming
out of Google brain or research or
something and it's a way to represent
different intermediate representations
like tensor flow graphs LLVM because
they have so many different rubbers this
isn't even showing all of their things
but you can see here they already have
tensor flow graph xla they have all
these other representations and they
need to translate between them as well
so even just inside Google this is a
problem for them for their internal
ecosystem so they're building this tool
ml IR to handle this so I want to look
at integrating with that or seeing you
know what are the similarities there
it's like a C++ first tool and this is
like a Python first tool so there might
be some differences but um they have a
similar intent and then otherwise really
we're just looking for use cases so if
you have a problem space or you maintain
a library and you are thinking hey you
know this library is great or I want to
solve this problem but I really need to
target like I need to target different
backends and I don't want the API to be
tied to those backends directly like if
that's how your problem is looking and
you need high performance then I think
this might be useful for you and we
should talk about it so yeah
all right if we have no more questions
just give a round of applause so thank
you